the nuclear question is increasingly
being asked i guess and it's not
necessarily being answered at this time
uh in the russian invasion of ukraine
but as time goes forward and as the um
takeover of ukraine does not go
nearly as quickly or nearly as smoothly
as reports indicate vladimir putin
expected it to go
the concern grows that maybe vladimir
putin would bring out the nuclear
weapons uh now when we talk about um
nuclear weapons this can mean a lot of
different things and i think some people
imagine
um
you know hiroshima
nagasaki that's not actually what's
being
considered here based on what russia has
and we're going to talk about that
but that's actually not necessarily a
good thing and i'll explain that in a
moment
an interesting article from defense one
concern rising that putin could use
nuclear weapons russian escalate to
de-escalate doctrine suggests putin is
thinking the unthinkable and patrick
tucker who's a technology editor writes
the world should take russia's
escalating nuclear threats very
seriously senior intel officials told
lawmakers tuesday noting they haven't
yet seen clear indications that putin
would respond to the military setbacks
in ukraine with nukes putin sparked
alarm among nuclear watchers last month
when he ordered the nuclear forces put
on a special regime of combat duty
um
and that uh speaking to lawmakers on
tuesday avril haynes the director of the
office of the director for national
intelligence said the move was mostly
signaling to keep nato from intervening
however
not everyone is so convinced that these
are these are merely empty
uh nuclear threats and then the question
is
what what do you what does it mean what
would it mean if russia actually nuked
ukraine well there's a lot of discussion
of that
and uh there's an article on
heritage.org that yes it's the heritage
foundation it's an accurate uh piece
russia's small nukes are a big problem
and it explains
russia has a ten to one advantage
over the us in non-strategic
low-yield nuclear weapons what are
sometimes called tactical or battlefield
nukes
and this is actually an area of concern
there are some who are hearing about
this and saying well
it's good that russia doesn't actually
have or would would not use the big
nukes here but the way in which it could
be a strategic disadvantage is because
russia has those battlefield or tactical
nukes
and nato
has a much smaller supply of those
putin knows
nato can't really respond
with those particular types of nukes and
this the concern is could actually be a
signal to putin
if i do this
they're not going to drop like the big
boy on russia
um so therefore
it might be an opportunity to use these
uh types of nuclear weapons tactical
nuclear weapons and
uh there's a lot of you know a lot of a
lot that you can read about these um
these are uh again sometimes called
non-strategic or sometimes called
tactical nuclear weapons and these are
designed to be used on the battlefield
with friendly forces in proximity
in contested areas when we think about
hiroshima nagasaki we're talking about
bombs of such
uh
uh potential to devastate that these are
dropped
when your forces are nowhere nearby with
with sort of wholesale disregard for the
devastation that they're going to cause
the type that is being discussed here
when we say putin might use nukes we're
talking about lower explosive power
um and designed to be targeted much more
specifically now am i saying that it's
it's uh of surgical precision of course
not
of course not but the idea is it doesn't
cause
wholesale devastation and fallout uh
like what we saw in uh in japan during
world war ii so that's the concern
concern is growing and certainly um you
know there's two sides to
how to interpret this going much longer
than putin may have hoped or imagined it
would go on the one hand there's well
that's a good thing putin thought maybe
they could take ukraine in three days
five days seven days it's not happening
they're being met with significantly
more resistance in ukraine and this
could demoralize
and potentially get putin to pull back
that's one side that's the optimistic
side the other side of this from a
strategic standpoint is well
putin expected it to go quickly and it's
not
so it's uh going to push him towards
taking more drastic action and that's
where these tactical or non-strategic
nuclear weapons could come in obviously
we hope that doesn't happen and uh there
really are no i i think the one
additional thing i would say about it is
there is a contingent
that is saying
give me a break
putin
nukes nuclear liberation not gonna
happen
but these are the same people who said
putin massing troops at the border
that's not happening well yes it is
here's the satellite imagery
putin about to invade the donetsk and
luhansk not going to happen and then
putin does
putin going to push further into ukraine
it's not going to happen and then
russian troops do
a lot of the same people saying there is
no nuclear threat from putin
are the same people who said he's not
massing troops at the border he's not
going to cross the border he's not going
to cross further over the border and all
of those things happen so i wouldn't pay
particular attention to those people
i want to play for you
uh a fascinating video um the ukrainian
president vladimir zelensky spoke
yesterday via uh
you know satellite uplink or or maybe
over the internet via teleconference
with um or to british parliament and
received a standing ovation and we're
going to just kind of catch up on a few
of the different things that took place
over the last 24 hours
here is uh the russian president the
ukrainian president rather addressing
you british parliament about the russian
invasion of his country ukraine
for your help
for the help of the civilized countries
we are we are thankful for this help
and i'm very grateful to you boris
please increase the pressure of
sanctions
against this
country and please recognize this
country as a terrorist state
and please make sure that our ukrainian
skies are safe
please make sure
that
you do
what needs to be done
and
what is stipulated by the greatness of
your country
best of all to ukraine and
to the united kingdom
it's
truly remarkable that a president who by
all accounts and i'm talking about
zolensky here
was
sort of okay you know before this and
not particularly well liked has
rapidly become
a hero
not only within ukraine
but internationally and we can debate
whether in the totality of what is
zelinski's legacy
that makes sense
uh it is not really the debate for today
because it is what is happening uh being
being held up as a hero and i mean
listen
uh when you look at what he's doing he
uh every opportunity to have left and so
many other things that that he chose to
do which he didn't have to i understand
why this is the reaction regardless of
what our thoughts about zolensky would
have been even as recently as six weeks
ago now what is happening in the russian
invasion of ukraine we are learning
about yet another one of these columns
of armored vehicles and tanks pushing
further into ukraine
we are learning about the refugee crisis
of individuals leaving ukraine many as
quickly as they possibly can on trains
even walking over the border i was
watching as i often do argentinian news
and
argentina has reporters on the ukrainian
polish border
and i mean just
children walking across the border truly
heartbreaking images
in terms of the economic sanctions
yesterday i reported to you that the
united states is banning
russian oil imports and we'll have video
a little bit later of joe biden
announcing that we also have now learned
that the united kingdom will be banning
russian oil imports as well
in a new sanctions move when you look at
a map like the one we have on the screen
right now
you see
the significant dependence on russian
oil
from much of eastern europe in
particular poland and hungary and and
other countries
western europe much less reliant on
russian oil and so uh saying we are not
going to
um
accept russian oil imports a much less
impactful decision although still having
a major impact on oil markets also over
the last 24 hours
maria baranova
the
now former editor-in-chief of russia
today which is state-run media
you might know it as rt
maria baranova has now resigned as the
editor-in-chief of rt
after condemning the invasion of ukraine
she is well aware that anyone who speaks
out against the kremlin could be in
danger but personal safety is the least
of her concerns
uh she said the problem is i know these
people very well they never send threats
they just kill so there is a kind of
weird silence around me but i really
think we're on the brink of a nuclear
war right now i'm not exaggerating i
have a son i can't leave because his
father won't allow me to leave with him
so i just prefer to stay in moscow it
seems like we're either in north korea
or we're going to be killed by a
thermonuclear mushroom i wouldn't quit
and i wouldn't lose my salary and job if
i were sure that we are going to be
alive for many years but i really don't
know what is going to happen to all of
us next
unbelievable unbelievable situation and
uh you know at the at the beginning the
question was would will this be days or
will this be weeks
more recently the conversation is will
this be weeks or will it be months with
some
uh
analyses from foreign ministries
briefing lawmakers that this could be
years to some degree
so we will watch it every 24 hours
bringing significant news
and the refugee crisis is getting
absolutely heartbreaking to an even
greater extent than it was last week uh
and we're going to talk about more uh
we'll talk more about the refugee
situation on tomorrow's show in the
meantime let me know how long do you
believe the current state of affairs
will last in ukraine let me know on
twitter where you can find me at d
pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is community
supported media you you are part of that
community and i would love it if you
signed up at
joinpackman.com and grabbed a membership
we do an extra show every day we've got
this show the one hour podcast which is
free to everybody but then we do an
additional show
for our members you also get the daily
show six hours earlier than everybody
else when you sign up at joinpacman.com
yesterday i reported to you that the
united states would be banning russian
oil imports and within hours of that the
u.s did indeed ban russian oil imports
and it did again send oil prices up and
we are continuing to see nominally
record gas prices and we may soon see
inflation-adjusted record gas prices
we're not there yet but i will let you
know when we do get there yesterday joe
biden made a public statement announcing
the sanctions but in addition
joe biden said during his statement
russia is not going to take ukraine
putin's not going to win and of course
many people liked hearing this but it
also raises questions about
well how far is joe biden willing to go
to make sure that that's the case that's
the question we'll discuss in a moment
here's joe biden yesterday
that'll mean tyrants like putin won't be
able to use fossil fuels as weapons
against other nations
and it will make america a world leader
manufacturing and exporting clean energy
technology of the future to countries
all around the world
this is the goal we should be racing
toward
over the last two weeks the ukrainian
people have inspired the world and i
mean that in a literal sense they've
inspired the world with their bravery
their patriotism their defiant
determination to live free
putin's war putin's war has caused
enormous suffering and needless loss of
life of women children everyone in
ukraine
both ukraine and i might add russians
ukrainian leaders as well as leaders
around the world have repeatedly called
for a ceasefire
for humanitarian relief
for real diplomacy
but putin seems determined to continue
on his murderous path no matter the cost
putin's now targeting cities and has
been targeting cities in civilian
schools hospitals apartment buildings
last week he attacked the largest
nuclear power plant in europe with an
apparent disregard for the potential of
triggering a nuclear meltdown
he has already turned 2 million
ukrainians into refugees
russia may continue to grind out its
advance at a horrible price
but this much is already clear
ukraine will never be a victory for
putin
so of course we all want to believe well
most of us maybe the guy i'm going to
play a clip of next doesn't but most of
us want to believe that that's the case
that this you can't do what putin has
done
and win and get away with it and annex
or take over ukraine or install a puppet
government or whatever the case may be
the question is
can joe biden really be sure of that
without ever committing u.s troops to
ukraine now from the beginning i've said
i don't want u.s troops going to ukraine
and joe biden has said u.s troops will
not go to ukraine there's no question
about that i'm not changing that or
arguing against that
the question is
is joe biden in a position to guarantee
that vladimir putin will not take
ukraine
and at the same time be sure that that
is possible
without even potentially committing
troops to the fight i don't know the
answer to that it's sort of an empirical
question about the military power and
what nato is potentially willing to do
now of course there's this in between
right where
the u.s is part of nato
and is there some
technically accurate scenario
in which the us
doesn't send troops to ukraine
in a direct sense
but does through nato if nato chooses to
enter and then it becomes
it's almost like a semantic question
right is are those u.s troops because
they're fighting under nato or not it
becomes a semantic question
but the question remains
how can joe biden really ensure putin
doesn't win
without being willing to send troops and
is that militarily
logical uh and i don't have the answer
there's different opinions about that
depending on what military analysts
opinions uh you you follow
one other clip i want to play for you as
i did mention yesterday joe biden
announcing the ban on russian oil and
gas imports
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
this is a move that has strong
bipartisan support the congress and i
believe in the country
americans have rallied support have
rallied to support their ukrainian
people and made it clear we will not be
part of subsidizing putin's war
this made we made this decision in close
consultation with our allies and our
partners around the world particularly
in europe
because a united response to putin's
aggression has been my overriding focus
to keep
all
nato and all of the eu and our allies
totally united
so the question about what will happen
with gas prices is a real question as i
have said to many of you before you know
i i don't play political games with this
stuff okay as i've said to you before
when gas prices are up 12 cents
and republicans go crazy and say this is
our death knell in an attack on the
middle class we do the math and we look
at the average number of miles driven by
the average person
and what we're talking about over the
period of a month from a 12 increase in
gas prices is a few bucks okay and for
most people it doesn't make a real
difference in terms of their budget
we are now talking about something
different
we are now talking about gas
already averaging uh i believe it was
yesterday was 419 a gallon i think now
we're up to 429 a gallon
uh and could be going up to 520 it's a
we are now talking about significantly
more expensive gas that will start
having an impact on many people's
monthly budgets because of
trucking expenses also increasing it
will have trickle-down impact on
products that people are buying now what
is there any upside the upside is
that after i mean listen at this point
it's probably been
close to a month of increasing crude oil
prices
as of right now as of this moment of me
recording today's show crude oil prices
are down five percent
and what this could be is that well
everything that can be done has
basically been done
and the crude oil market is essentially
a futures market it reflects what do we
expect about the supply of oil in the
future
and we've seen the price of crude oil
continually go up
as expectations for supply crunches are
priced in as we hear announcements about
what's going to be done we may and these
could i might end up eating my hat when
crude oil gets to 150 or 200 bucks per
barrel we hit 124 yesterday we're now
down to 117.
it's conceivable that the uncertainty
has all now been priced in we just don't
know and again that's just based on
what's going on literally as of this
moment with crude oil down five percent
so the announcement is made
and uh
we it it is a serious thing
and it is a global issue it is not joe
biden's fault as i explained to you
yesterday
fox news has been regularly bringing on
a so-called invasion expert to give his
analysis
of what's going on in the russian
invasion of ukraine and oops lo and
behold
it turns out that the guy
is a trump-appointed putin propagandist
this guy's name is douglas mcgregor
douglas mcgregor has appeared with
tucker carlson and all he's all over fox
news
as a so as a so-called expert on the
invasion and it turns out he's one of
these sort of putin defenders who at one
point was actually appointed by donald
trump listen to this this is a very good
article from rolling stone outlining the
entire thing um
which says
trump at one point
nominated considered mcgregor for a
number of different jobs ultimately
nominated him to be the u.s ambassador
to germany
ultimately the nomination didn't pan out
when cnn reported on mcgregor's history
of racism trump was undeterred
appointing mcgregor as a pentagon senior
adviser shortly after the 2020 election
this guy is a bonkers pro-putin guy okay
let's look at some clips here he is
arguing against sanctions basically
saying the sanctions are futile it's not
going to hurt it's not going to hurt
putin it's not going to hurt russia
the sanctions as you rightly point out
will do a lot of damage to us they're
not going to make much difference to
russia
china will stand with russia it knows it
has to russia has an abundance of food
and energy china will take it all now
everything he said there is wrong
he's the guy's just wrong number one
although initially russia said we don't
care about the sanctions they're not
doing anything to us
russia later conceded actually the
sanctions are very damaging and painful
and it even led to putin uh putting
nuclear uh
uh elements of nuclear deterrence on
higher alert so
it was wrong that russia would not be
impacted by the sanctions and then
number two this idea that china will
never ever ever do anything anything
anything against russia in the last 24
hours china has started for the first
time
referring to what russia has done in
ukraine as an invasion and as a war and
this is not something that they
previously had done so even on that he
is wrong as well
next clip mcgregor went on fox news this
time with stuart varney and said the
russian army is actually it's been too
gentle
but now it's going to get everything
done within 10 days he called zolensky a
delusional puppet
and he said that all of the ukrainian
claims about what's going on are
propaganda wow
all of that is also false the
first five days
uh russian forces i think frankly were
too gentle
they've now corrected that so i would
say another 10 days this should be
completely over but the question is
uh what is it that zielinski is going to
do the russians have made it very clear
what they want is a neutral ukraine
this could have ended days ago if he
accepted that
and then they could guys if only
zielenski accepted the invasion this
would have ended a long time ago just
the borders but the eastern part of
ukraine is firmly in russian hands by
the way when he says adjust the borders
he's saying allow russia to steal the
land
but again the russians are not seizing
territory they're destroying ukrainian
forces that's their focus colonel it
sounds like you don't approve of
zelinski's stand
well i think zielinski is a puppet
and he is putting huge numbers of his
own population at unnecessary risk
and uh quite frankly most of what comes
out of ukraine is debunked as lies
within 24 to 48 hours that's also
completely untrue and uh once again
um
he said that it was only going to be 10
more days he said this back on march 4th
or 5th which means within five or six
days
uh according to this expert on invasions
russia should have taken ukraine my
prediction is that will not have
happened five to six days from now and
then lastly here he is saying uh we
gotta stop demonizing putin come on does
not want to do
in our usual effort to demonize him and
his country we need to remember that
ukraine is fourth from the bottom of 158
countries in the world
as corrupt russia is perhaps three or
four places above them this is not the
liberal democracy now i don't know what
he's citing there but as many of you
know
in multiple serious democracy indices
ukraine ranks much higher in democracy
than russia shining example that
everyone says it is far from it mr
zielinski has jailed journalists and his
political opposition
i think we need to stay out of it the
american people think we should stay out
of it the europeans think we should stay
out of it now that's also not true the
american people although they're they
don't want to commit troops and i agree
with that
the american people think we should be
arming and supporting ukraine i mean you
can you can say that that's wrong but
what mcgregor is saying is just
completely incorrect
he is the wrongest man you know how alex
berenson is the wrongest man in america
on covid
mcgregor seems to be the wrongest man in
america on russia ukraine and fox
continues bringing him on as an expert
when he's really just a putin
propagandist who couldn't even get the
position trump uh selected him for
because of his outrageous racist past
that came out we'll have these clips
that i played on our instagram at david
pakman show if you want to check them
out
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show okay the arrests continue to be
made in relation to the january 6 trump
riots even though it's been uh 14 months
and three days
since the day of the riots we still see
arrests being made and some of these are
major and the latest one is that proud
boys leader enrique tario has been
arrested
in his underoos he was pulled out of bed
yes uh boxers of briefs not exactly the
main question that um law enforcement
was asking when they pulled him out of
bed and arrested him this is a this is a
major major deal daily beast reporting
proud boys leader dragged out of bed in
his underwear to face conspiracy charge
and apparently taken by complete
surprise former proud boys ringleader
enrique tario was handcuffed in nothing
but his skivvies early tuesday morning
as police arrived at his miami home to
arrest him for conspiracy
relating to the january sixth
insurrection in footage of the arrest 38
year old tario can be seen exiting with
his house ra his hands raised
surrendering to police he wasn't at the
riot having been unavoidably detained
that is arrested two days before for
burning a stolen black lives matter flag
but the feds allege he organized
alongside five other proud boys members
the attack on the capital the riot was
the final stage of a convoluted plot
involving a flurry of text messages
social media posts and a meeting in a dc
parking garage on january 5th
tario was released from prison for the
flag burning incident two months ago he
has now been arrested once again the the
video is pretty wild
um we have there's video of him uh being
pulled out of the house in his uh in his
ruse as i mentioned um
and uh the next thing would be well it
would be great if the politicians who
supported the january sixth insurrection
were treated in the exact same way it
would it would really be something by
the way
uh to say
to see josh hawley arrested in a diaper
i'm sorry in his underwear um it would
really be something else and it would
even be more interesting to see attorney
general merrick garland in his pajamas
arresting trump wearing uh wearing
briefs or whatever in all seriousness
this enrique tario guy is really really
not a good guy now some of you may know
about the proud boys and some may not
the proud boys is a
far
far far right what's called neo-fascist
group by many
it's
as far as i know it's an exclusively
male organization although it's
conceivable that i mean i don't know how
official membership is anyway it's
conceivable there may be there may be
some uh women involved
to some degree
tario specifically
is um
cuban american and afro-cuban ethnically
uh some say well that's kind of uh kind
of interesting that this right-wing
neo-fascist group
allows him in or whatever uh but uh yes
they as long as you are willing to have
the right views there apparen apparently
are no race-based tests for neo-fascist
proud boy membership but this guy could
really be facing
very very serious penalties and for if
the name sounds familiar
for a year
there has been discussion of is tario
going to be arrested
for his role in inciting planning
whatever the january six riots
and uh the answer is that indeed he has
been and of course uh when it takes this
usually from what i've been reading and
some of the lawyers i spoke to when
things take this long it's because they
really
it's not because they wait until later
investigators
for the more serious charges it's that
the more serious charges
often are more complicated to prove and
to feel good that you're ready to charge
and so it just takes longer to build the
case that's what lawyers have told me
um and and we will ultimately see what
happens with tario but we expected that
this was potentially coming uh and it
now has
ted cruz um has gone viral
and it's not good i don't know that ted
cruz has ever gone viral for something
good i remember when ted cruz sort of
humiliated himself by apparently
accidentally
liking porn on twitter
um and then they blamed it on
a staffer or something like that
and then ted cruz went viral when trump
called his wife ugly
and ted cruz went viral when he left
texas during the power outages and went
to cancun if ted cruz has gone viral
it's usually not good and ted cruz has
now gone viral for sort of his version
of what we call the sir routine so let
me let me explain that to you
um
ted cruz yesterday
had a meeting with the dc trucker convoy
people now there's there's so many
things going on here the dc trucker
convoy is the american version of the
canadian trucker convoy who drove around
burning gas and diesel
uh and honking their horns
in a principled and defiant protest
against mandates now you might be saying
david what mandates are there are they
talking about yeah i don't know i don't
know i mean the main mandate which was
for vaccination or testing
if your business has more than 100
employees
the supreme court stopped that
uh
many if not most city mandates for
required vaccination to go places like
restaurants etc
those are being dropped i don't actually
know what what mandates they're
protesting but in any case ted cruz met
with the trucker convoy and he claimed
that
flight attendants and pilots regularly
hug him they regularly hug him
because
he fights the vaccine mandates this
almost certainly didn't happen this is a
version of the sir routine that trump is
known for take a listen every week i fly
back and forth to houston right almost
without exception every time i'm on i'm
on an airplane
either the captain or a flight attendant
will come up to me
will hug me and say thank you for
fighting for us because i'll tell you
united airlines sadly houston is a hub
of them
has fired thousands of pilots and flight
attendants now that's a lie
that's a lie
uh united has about i believe 60 000
us-based employees
and 200 people were let go for not
getting vaccinated 200 not thousands do
the facts matter probably not
what difference does it make we're in
the district of columbia right now there
are mandates affecting kids in dc
this is wrong okay
so
this is a version of trump's sir routine
trump sir routine is when trump goes you
know they came to me and they said sir
sir sure
thank you for doing this with a tear in
their eye they came to me and said thank
you sir
for allowing unvaccinated people to be
all over me and spread um it's almost
always a lie when trump says they came
to me and they said sir it's almost
always a lie when trump says and nobody
really knows that
it's almost always a lie when trump says
and it's really a shame we won this
election
but they stole it and it's really a
shame those are triggers that it's
probably a lie
with ted cruz
i mean i think any time ted cruz is
claiming others deliberately made
physical contact with
with him
it's probably a lie and i can't imagine
that flight attendants and pilots are
coming up to him and hugging him and
saying thank you thank you for allowing
and encouraging unvaccinated people to
be getting on our airplanes and uh often
i'm guessing those are the very same
people that uh wear the mask under the
chin on the plane
because they just don't know what the
hell is going on or or just don't care
but again the truth is
united airlines 96 000 global employees
about 60 000 of those i think my numbers
are right
are based in the united states and of
those 60 000
200 were let go for being unvaccinated
and for a very long period i don't know
if it's still but for a very long period
of time
once united put in place their vaccine
requirement
they
their employees stopped dying of the
virus now it's been so long now it's
certainly conceivable that now
um some some vaccinated employee has
died of the virus it's certainly
possible but for a very long stretch of
time they were not uh give me a break
ted cruz continuing to just tell these
stories and by the way
why is he meeting with this trucker
convoy what i would love to see cruz ask
instead of ranting and raving in this
kind of like faux
defiant tone
about vaccines i would love to see him
ask the truckers
exactly which mandates are you here in
opposition to exactly which ones tell me
because there's barely any left and all
of the restrictions are falling by the
wayside all right so that's ted cruz uh
and um there are people who see him as a
hero
i don't but there are people who do
we're going to take a quick break and be
back right after this make sure you're
following us on facebook
at facebook.com
david pakman show
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
okay i want to talk about william barr
again today i know we've we've talked
about him already this week
william barr
has a new book william barr is donald
trump's former attorney general and in
the book barr makes all sorts of
explosive claims and he's been doing
some interesting interviews now i i want
to make sure my position on barr is
clear
i believe his stories are all true i
don't think william barr is making up
the stories that he tells about donald
trump and we're going to listen to
another completely wacky one in a moment
that being said
i see barr as just as much of a problem
as all of these other trumpian clowns
and barr even said yesterday that
despite all of the stuff that trump did
that barr finds completely disgusting he
would still vote for trump over a
democrat in 2024 if trump were the
nominee so
the guy is still despicable he's just
trying to sell a book but i do think
he's telling the truth and you have to
hear the story that he told bret baier
yesterday on fox news
barr describes
a completely detached from reality trump
who in in the aftermath of the 2020
election when it was obvious to anybody
with common sense that joe biden won
and that joe biden would be president
trump according to barr
genuinely believed he was going to be
president for another four years and
we've said before
does did trump believe this stuff or was
it just a griff then by the end it
didn't really matter because trump was
still fundraising on the basis that he
was going to fight the results and
whatever it didn't really matter whether
trump believed it or not but according
to what barr tells brett bayer
trump really did believe he had won and
that he would somehow take the white
house from joe biden listen to this man
were unsettling moment
for you
in the administration it was certainly
unsettling when i went in to talk to the
president about the election and uh
you know he was
livid and shaking and you know showed a
lot of
temper
and yelling
that was a little unsettling but the
other thing that was actually unsettling
is later when i went in to actually give
him my letter of resignation
uh he started talking about how he had
actually won the election and how the
machines were rigged and that he was
actually going to be there for another
term and he was very confident of that
and i
i just felt
this showed a detachment from reality
that was stunning
completely disconnected from reality i
mean what again i believe barr
and what barr describes there
is
a very delusional person and any
person thinking through the events of
the trump administration in
understanding what william barr is
saying trump believed he won
and he believed he would somehow end up
spending four more years in the white
house if he was that detached from
reality about something so basic about
uh
the election's over
biden one biden's going to be the
president you're going to leave you're
going to leave
either by by your under your power or
that of someone dragging you out
if he was that disconnected from reality
about something so simple as how
elections work
what else was going on where trump
simply didn't understand the nuts and
bolts of what he was involved in and of
course we have to assume
the putin conversations the north korea
negotiations
all of these different things when we
hear trump asked whether you could you
could nuke a hurricane well he's just
that disconnected from reality that's
how sick he is now
william barr is no hero as i told you
yesterday even despite all this william
barr
still told savannah guthrie
she'd still choose trump over a democrat
and that's why we have to remember these
people are like 98
in the cult rather than a hundred
percent
you say in your book it's time for the
party to move on from trump liz cheney
has said he is not fit to serve and
should not be ever near the oval office
again do you agree with that
well i certainly
have made it clear i don't think he
should be our nominee and i'm going to
you know support somebody else for the
nomination but if he is the nominee and
you have your choices
donald trump or whoever's running on the
democratic side would you vote for him
uh
because i believe that the the greatest
threat to the country is the progressive
agenda being pushed by the democratic
party it's inconceivable to me that i
wouldn't vote for the republican nominee
so
even if he lied about the election and
threatened democracy as you write in
your book well it's better than a
democrat it's hard to project what the
facts are going to turn out to be three
years hence but as of now it's hard for
me to conceive that i wouldn't vote for
the republican nominee a threat to
democracy
a threat to democracy unfit to serve
delusional detachment from reality and
yet i would still vote for the guy
because it's better than a democrat
just as a couple of reminders and i know
some of you have seen these clips
already here is barr saying
he told trump all the election stuff
you're saying is bs and i told him that
all this stuff was blue
and
about election fraud
and uh
you know it was wrong to be shoveling it
out the way his team was
and he started asking me about different
theories and i had the answers i was
able to tell him this is wrong because
of this you're trying to set him
straight yes and and and you know he
listened
he he he was obviously getting very
angry about this i said okay well look i
i understand you're upset with me
and i'm perfectly happy to tender my
resignation and then boom he slaps the
desk he slapped the desk and he said
accepted
accept it
and then boom he slapped it again accept
it
go home don't go back to your office
go home
you're done
yeah
and lastly also bill barr describing the
clown show of lawyers but he would still
vote for trump over a democrat guys
and
about election fraud
and
it was wrong to be shoveling it out the
way his team was
and then he also told trump what he
thought of his legal team
not a lot
i said the reason you are where you are
is because you wheeled out a clown show
of lawyers
a clown show yeah clown car or something
like that i said it's just a bunch of
clowns
who are you referring to
rudy giuliani's cracker jack legal team
among others barr says the president
shot back listing the ways he said barr
had failed him yeah so anyway he'd still
vote so so i believe every single one of
these stories i do
but uh bar bar has not had some kind of
uh awakening back to common sense or
whatever um at the end of the day if
it's uh trump versus it sounds like any
democrat
despite the dangers that barr has um
associated trump with danger to
democracy unfit all this stuff
he'd still vote trump and that's why
it's just a reminder these are not
people we can count on to help us do
anything anything anything anything hey
this might be interesting and
informative for you guys as many of you
know
we get
five or so thousand messages a day
across all of our different platforms so
like youtube comments facebook comments
emails twitter replies all these
different things it's impossible to keep
up with all of it and so we we just
can't we just don't okay
every once in a while i like to engage
with someone so like six months ago
um an anti-vaxx emailer
piqued my interest and i said let me
reply and let's see what happens and
then i showed you that exchange and it
was really really wacky and disturbing
so i did it again okay i did it again
the other day
i tweeted about the jobs numbers now one
of the things we talked about on
yesterday's bonus show is
in the midst of everything going on
politically
the jobs numbers which are very good i
mean by every traditional measure
we're basically at full employment now
many of you will say but a lot of people
are still paycheck to paycheck and the
wages aren't good and the jobs are low
quality and people oh 100 i i'm with you
all the way i'm just saying that by
traditional measures which republicans
love to use when it's a republican
president
we are very close to what is considered
full employment and last week there were
extraordinary jobs numbers nearly 700
000 new jobs were created
uh in february we got the february
numbers last week these are very very
good numbers and so i simply tweeted
just to see kind of you know feel around
what's going on
the jobs numbers are very compelling
just really not a very controversial
tweet
and a guy named andrew responded to me
and said
you mean all the jobs biden destroyed
with his lockdown mania
now
as you can probably imagine there's like
three or four layers on which this is
this is very fallacious
we're talking about
job creation
right now jobs were gaining jobs
um and of course the job losses that we
saw
happened under donald trump and so so
the comment just it doesn't make any
sense but i said hey here's an
opportunity to try to figure out where
this person is coming from so the first
thing was i wanted to establish does the
person even know what i'm talking about
so i wrote back and i said
did you see the numbers today
because
they may not even know that i think it
was 678 000 jobs were created in
february they might just be responding
without having any idea what it is that
i'm talking about
and andrew wrote back and said yeah
meaning i did see the jobs numbers
you can't brag about job creation
when your party caused all the job loss
and again
bragging we're just talking about what
are the jobs numbers
is it good to create jobs
and if it is
if you blame who's in the oval office
when jobs are lost
don't they get credit when jobs are
created now you and i hopefully all of
us have a more nuanced understanding of
job creation and we understand that to
some degree
on a delay
job creation or job loss
partially reflects the actions of the
president
but to a significant degree has to do
with global factors
broader economic factors
and and things that have nothing to do
with the president but you've you've got
to be able to play both sides if you
blame a president for job loss you've
got to at least give some equivalent
amount of credit for job creation but
this person is so confused you can't
brag about job creation when your party
caused the job loss so i followed up and
tried to explain
i said quote
almost all the job loss
was in 2020
when donald trump was president what
exactly are you referring to
to which andrew responded
the needless policies that were under
democrats
via their governors and congressmen
they shut the country down needlessly
it's been shown many times lockdown
policies didn't help stop the spread
but hurt
devastated the economy and
so so a couple different things first of
all this experiment was basically a
waste of time and what i mean by that is
each response
moved the discussion to something
different
and it didn't even seem to comprehend
that time moves forward as we understand
it and who was president at different
points in time but it's also wrong on
some pretty basic facts number one
the economy
uh even by the end i mean listen i'm
glad to admit it because again it has it
has a little to do with the president
but not that much
by the end of trump's presidency
the economy was looking pretty okay
and it continued improving under joe
biden we now have a very shaky stock
market and inflation and we have these
global things but that trend
we were already seeing it under trump
and it continued under biden so even the
claim that everything that was done in
2020
hurt the economy irreversibly it's just
not true
but maybe more importantly
we learned that it doesn't matter even
if i try to engage in good faith and
understand where this person is coming
from
i posted about february jobs numbers
the guy responded and talked about job
losses from 2020
but blamed biden for them even though
trump was president then changed the
conversation to so-called democratic
lockdowns even though it was all under
trump's watch i mean it's red herring
after red herring after straw man after
red herring so
i think what i learned is this is a
waste of my time
and
i don't know because i don't know this
andrew guy i don't know if he's ignorant
and maybe cognitively limited in terms
of being able to engage on the facts
or whether he's arguing in bad faith or
whether he's just trolling me or whether
he was confused or whatever the case may
be i just don't know quite frankly
but needless to say
we didn't learn anything from that
conversation and i've probably had my
fill for at least a couple of months but
if i decide to do this again i'll come
i'll come back to you we have a
voicemail number that number is 219
to david p here is a voicemail caller
who asks about something that really
opens up a major can of worms major can
of worms take a listen to this
hey david so i've been slowly getting
more involved in the stock market
recently i was just wondering if you had
any
recommendations as to who
you might listen to for for advice for
that or
if you have anyone yourself
thanks
so listen here's the deal
you don't need to listen to anyone you
don't you don't need
my advice on this continues to be
pay
no attention to stock pickers or market
timers of any kind the advice is
the financial advising industry is 99
based on making really simple things
appear to be complicated so that you pay
someone for advice
is the stock market going up
keep buying index funds is the stock
market going down
keep buying index funds
that's it that's the strategy and then
just wait you've got to filter out the
noise and we've recently on live streams
been doing kind of debunkings of
so-called financial guru dave ramsey's
financial advice which is often sort of
like just right-wing christianity-based
it's it's it's not something i like to
get involved in myself um i've talked
before about the futility of picking
individual stocks if you believe
that you know something no one else does
and you can pick individual stocks and
know when to buy and when to sell
allocate some small amount of your
assets to that
and i consider it gambling i own some
individual stocks but the vast majority
should be in the lowest
possible cost
wide broad-based index funds
and over time
those tend to go up
and you don't need to worry about oh
well the market's down two percent do i
buy you you set up a schedule and that's
it i buy once a month on the first of
the month i buy twice a month the first
and the fifteenth if stocks are going
down if the market's going down you're
getting a discount great you keep buying
if stocks are going up the stuff you've
already bought becomes worth more uh and
then in terms of who to follow
if you believe
that someone in particular
has really great stock picking skills
whether you like dave ramsey or i doubt
he gives individual stock advice or like
jim cramer or some newsletter or
whatever
devote some small portion of your assets
but my advice is about who to get advice
from no one the strategy is buy
broad-based index funds
and just keep buying and uh next month
we're actually going to interview nick
majuli who just put out a book about
this saying you got to filter out the
noise this individual stock picking and
people saying get in now get out now
it's a distraction we'll talk about that
more next month we have a great bonus
show for you today mcdonald's is
temporarily closing 850 restaurants in
russia and it led to massive lines
outside of mcdonald's in russia we are
going to talk about the increase in the
portion of americans now living paycheck
to paycheck partially because of
inflation
um and we are also this is good news
congress has passed a bill
to
bolster the postal service without
cutting back on delivery which it looked
like they were going to be doing slowing
down and cutting back on delivery so all
good news and all of those stories are
on two days bonus show you can sign up
at joinpackman.com remember that alex
jones has issued an anti-endorsement of
the bonus show alex jones hates the
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
the fact that he is so against it should
make you think damn there's probably
something interesting happening on that
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com and
we have just a couple days left if you
would like to apply for
content coaching if you are a content
creator and you would like to
participate in free this is free
coaching we're gonna pick four or five
people we've had about a hundred apply
so far you can apply
at davidpakman.com coaching don't email
me about the coaching do emails will be
ignored
if you're interested apply
at davidpakman.com
[Music]